[Music]
today we are going back to the mid90s to
recreate a piece of technology very near
and dear to my heart the Game Boy Color
was my introduction to video games as a
7-year-old and single-handedly
responsible for my continued love of
games today throughout this project I
discovered not only how satisfying it
was to recreate this thing and it
running in real time but maybe more
importantly I was able to reconnect with
my childhood through this project and by
the end of this video we'll learn a ton
from creating a preset Unreal Engine
Master file that we can use before
starting any project Pro modeling tips
lighting tips and tricks getting the
most out of our textures with surface
imperfections to setting up Goos
time-saving animation techniques and
render settings leaving us with a
beautiful photoreal Game Boy Color to
customize to our heart's content so kick
back relax and join me on this quest to
the '90s
this video is sponsored by grayscale
Gorilla whose materials tools and assets
are now available everywhere you make 3D
art I'm also giving this project file
away for free for you guys to play with
which I'll get into later in the video
all right so if we're going to
accurately model texture and ultimately
light and render This Game Boy Color we
you need to gather reference and what
better way to do this than to get one in
hand this is true for anything we
recreate if you can get close to the
real thing do it because that's going to
be our ground truth moving forward and
the key to getting our shapes textures
colors and details correct now since I
don't have my original Game Boy Color I
finally have an excuse to buy one on
eBay so while that ships let's dig for
some old cartridges since moving from my
hometown of Chino Hills California to
Atlanta Georgia I have started this box
of memories where I put things that I
think I'll want to have later on in life
and I'm pretty sure I got some old
Pokémon cartridges in here now since
we're going to model these bad boys
let's take a few reference pictures in
this little Studio Box thing I got on
Amazon for super cheap we'll take a
front back side top and bottom shot will
clean them up in Lightroom by
straightening cropping and perhaps
brightening the image as a touch our
cartridge reference is complete and I'll
follow the same process for the Game
Boy where set up to start modeling these
bad
boys now if we want our 3D models to
hold up in a close-up shot and look
clean when it's all reflective and
whatnot our topology needs to be clean
our Loop Cuts precise and our edges
beveled to Perfection and honestly I'm
just not the guy to pull this one off it
take me like 2 years and a day to get
right and I'd rather just focus on the
lighting and materials anyway so let's
summon a 3D modeling
master
so one of my Discord moderators MDK is
really good at 3D modeling I mean really
good and I knew he was definitely the
one to commission for this job and since
I don't want this to be the end of the
modeling section here are some Pro tips
from MDK in an interview I did with him
about the process MDK started with a
rough perimeter and once completed
roughed in the back piece same for the
front and merged them together he
equates it to completing the the border
of a jigsaw puzzle first then working
your way in toward the center MDK
actually broke up and modeled the
separate pieces the same way the real
thing is separated and mentions modeling
in this way makes for a much easier
process he says that clean topology and
Edge flow in a subdivided model have a
few things an even spacing of foursided
square polygons minimal amount of
triangles and poles no endons in the
model and a minimal amount of geometry
needed to achieve the intended in shape
he also mentions that this is just the
best case scenario and on personal
projects rules should definitely be
broken just as long as what you're going
for comes through planning ahead can
help reduce trial and error for problem
areas MDK mentions for example with the
speaker having edges flow between the
holes made for a much easier process but
he also mentions organic or complex
shapes always come with some difficulty
it certainly took manual work and time
to get things just right if you guys
want to show MDK some love for this
incredible model that he put together go
follow his art station page check him
out he's got an incredible portfolio
built out over there I got a link Down
Below in the description for you
guys now you guys can use whatever
program that you'd like but I'll be
using unre engine today which most of
you guys know by now is free and linked
below all right so when you launch
whatever version I'm using 5.3 you'll
see this page here I'll select the game
preset I'll select the basic level and
enable race tracing if we don't click
this we'll have to menu dive to ensure
it's set up properly which is super
annoying and slow so check in this box
bypasses us having to do that we can
also enable starter content if we want
some basic materials and walls to mess
around with but I'll leave it unchecked
for now when our scene opens we can fly
around by holding right click and using
the W and D Keys like we're in a
first-person shooter honestly I just
wish every software would adopt these
controls they're just the best we can
control the camera sensitivity with the
scroll wheel or the slider up in the top
right q and E will raise or lower the
camera F will snap the viewport to any
selected object space bar Cycles between
our position scale and rotation gizmos
control back tick will switch between
local and World orientation G will show
or hide icons and if you don't see your
content browser at the bottom of your
screen you can press control plus space
bar to open it up and dock it in the
layout by pressing the button on the
right now let's optimize this scene for
for the very best settings again we only
have to do this once then we can save
our project as a default project file
once complete let's start by importing
our Game Boy and cartridge meshes so we
have something to frame up default
settings are fine here I'll select all
our parts drag them into the viewport
and group them with contrl G to make
life easier next let's create a camera
if you don't see the place actors window
on the left you can toggle it via window
Place actors and search for a cine
camera actor drag it out right click it
and pilot the camera sweet now feel free
to adjust your aspect ratio under the
film back settings your lens settings
essentially control the boundaries of
how far you can push your current focal
length and aperture and if we want to
keep an object in Focus we can set our
Focus method to tracking and select the
object we'd like to focus on to control
exposure add vignette film green Bloom
color correction and tweak viewport
render settings we'll search for a
postprocess volume drag it out type
Unbound and check this box here this
ensures that our changes occur worldwide
rather than just within this box and to
counteract this Auto exposure currently
happening I'll search for brightness and
set these two EV values to
one let's talk Ray TRC versus Lumin
Reflections for a second and I got a
chrome material on our Game Boy to show
the difference that this will make I'll
select my post-process volume and search
for Reflections you'll notice our method
is currently set to Lumin and if we want
slightly higher quality Lumin
Reflections we can change the lighting
mode to hit lighting for Reflections but
in our case we want to toggle Ray traced
Reflections and Bam the difference here
is huge cuz it really cleans up the
reflections they're simply more accurate
now and not as fuzzy if your Reflections
look grainy though we'll want to throw
more samples at it by searching for rate
traced adding a couple more bounces so
we get Reflections in Reflections and
some more samples to clean up that noise
now go easy here you can start with 4 8
maybe even 16 and then you can work your
way up to 32 or 64 if your rig can
handle it you'll want to balance
performance and quality here and a good
way to check performance is by enabling
the FPS stat right up here and we're
just about ready to get started on this
thing the last thing I'll do is toggle a
handful of plugins I know I'll use all
the time namely an hdri backdrop which
we'll use later on the movie render
queue and its settings for when we
render our scene later the data Smith
c4d importer if I want to drag c4d
scenes in and I think that's it for now
you can save this as your default scene
now so that when you start up any new
project you'll just duplicate this
folder structure open it up and you're
ready to get
creating and speaking of creating let's
start with the lighting cuz in order to
texture this thing accurately we have to
light it in a certain way first
specifically in a way that catches the
Contours of our model in a pleasant way
making it easy to determine how shiny
certain materials need to be or how much
grunge or scratches they need without a
nice lighting setup we're essentially
gonna be texturing in the dark and in my
opinion the easiest way to get that set
up is with an hdri hdris as you know are
high dynamic range images which you can
use to light your scene with it's
freaking sweet and if you want to go the
extra mile and make your own custom hdri
like I did of my office here for example
or anywhere else in the world you can
check out this video where I go over the
whole process I highly recommend it as
it's really fun to do and a great skill
to have as a 3D and bfx artist
anyway let's drag my hdri into the
content browser search for an hdri
backdrop from the place actor window
drag it in and drop the hdri into the
cube map area here now our scene is lit
by this image of my office if we expose
down so will this image that's what
makes them so special it's real lighting
data coming from these things but I
don't want this floor that the hdri
backdrop sets up for us so I'll uncurl
the advanced Tab and check use camera
projection fixed
and if this hdri isn't lighting your
object correctly for whatever reason
just change the size from 150 to, 1500
then we should be looking good feel free
to up the intensity if you want a bit
more punch rotate it or swap out the
hdri for a whole new
look now before I start texturing I want
to invite you guys to download This Game
Boy project file for free and follow
along with me asset wise I'll be tapping
into the material library from grayscale
gorilla
the sponsor of today's video grayscale
gorilla is the place for the highest
quality materials specifically built for
close-ups like this and detailed product
shots their library of 4,000 plus
highquality assets cover everything from
materials hdis surface imperfections
Goos models IES profiles and as of last
week gra SK gorilla plus is now
accessible to all 3D applications and
they built plugins for unreal blender
Houdini and Cinema 4D users to make
material import super easy Nick Campbell
started this thing 15 years ago as a way
to share his c4d knowledge with you guys
and to young artists like myself at the
time and since then we have bonded over
our love for art and music at various 3D
meetups so I'm real happy to be sharing
this one with you guys today go sign up
for free grab a bunch of free assets
including this game boy project file I
got a link below for you guys and if you
like what you see hop on their monthly
subscription maybe grab a year and get
immediate access to their entire library
and without further Ado guys let's
texture this game boy okay so after
downloading and unzipping some materials
into a folder I'll ensure the GSG plugin
is enabled and click this little button
here to navigate to that root folder
with all our materials hit select all
and import and we got a GSG folder with
all our Master materials and material
instances which will be using to create
different colored versions of this game
boy so let's just get started with this
plastic and at first it's looking like
some alligator skin so let's scale it
down by opening the instance I'll check
the tiling SL offset and increase these
X and Y values much better nice but what
if we want to adjust the brightness the
reflectivity the roughness or the normal
amounts how can we do that unreal is a
bit different from other programs in the
sense that you have to build what you
would get for free in other programs so
let's open up one of these Master
materials and I'll show you how simple
it is to get it set up in the color
Channel I'll start with a simple
brightness adjustment by creating a
multiply node by either right clicking
and searching for multiply or doing it
the fast way by holding M and left
clicking then let's create a scalar
parameter which is basically just a
fancy way of saying an adjustable number
by holding s and left clicking I'll call
it brightness set it to one by default
and if we plug this into the multiply
node as well as the texture we have a
little brightness adjustment and I use
this simple setup all the time to give
me basic control over different textures
and I'll do the same here for our
roughness and specular intensity as well
but if there's nothing in the roughness
or specular slots you could just right
click the attribute on the material
properties and promote it to a parameter
set it to whatever default number and
you've got control additionally we can
add saturation and tint controls for the
color channel so for saturation I'll
make a desaturate node with a scalar
parameter set to one piped into a one
minus node by holding o and left
clicking because we want to saturate as
opposed to desaturate right and for tin
controls all create a basic solid or
technically a constant three Vector as
it's called in Unreal Engine by holding
down three and left clicking and I'll
set it to White by default and pipe that
into multiply along with our color
correction chain and if we right click
the constant 3 vector and call it tint
we can change the color to tint our
texture and lastly let's control our
normal texture by creating a flattened
normal node with a scalar parameter of
one plugged into flatten the normal
texture plugged into normal and all of
that that plugged into the material's
normal slot but with this setup we're
again doing the opposite of what we want
a normal Power of one should be as if we
just pluged the normal map into the
material so I'll add that one minus node
after the scalar parameter to counteract
it and this is going to come in handy
when making a smooth and shiny version
of this material for the smooth parts of
our game boy now let's save this master
material we'll make a copy of our rough
plastic material instance and I'll drop
it on to the shiny Bits And if we open
up the new instance we can see our
custom parameters here I'll toggle the
ones we want we'll set the normal power
to zero and make any other adjustments
making sure to go back to my game boy as
reference for what this thing should
actually look like let's throw down some
dark gray plastic for the buttons get a
screen material going and a metal
texture from gsg's library for the
screws and the backing where the
cartridge slides
in for the torn barcodes and system in
stickers on the back of the Game Boy I
just took a couple close-up shots with
my phone craft it in Photoshop and made
a normal map by going to filter 3D
generate normal I made the simplest of
materials with those images and added
some specular and roughness parameters
to lock in the correct look but what
about surface imperfections that's one
of the best parts about this are the
scratches the grunge the grime it just
makes it come alive it tells a story and
it makes it feel used so let me show you
how we can take the materials we already
have set up up and incorporate some
surface imperfections now if you've
already downloaded this project file
from Grace go gorilla in you should
already see the surface imperfections
I'll be using in the content browser
I'll click our screen to navigate to the
material in our content browser and open
up the master materials I'll drag in the
surface imperfection and pipe it into
the roughness Channel but you'll notice
it changes the entire look of our screen
so we'll want to build a little setup
that gives us full control over the
amount of roughness our screen gets and
that's where the lurp node comes in hey
what you call me it's like a mix RGB
node in blender or a mixed texture in
Octane and basically allows us to blend
between two different values using the
surface imperfection as the driver so I
have my roughness Min set to zero with a
Max of one and my roughness Max set to
one also with a Max of one you can also
give it a tiling material function to
control its scale and rotation if we
save and close and open up our material
instance we can adjust these values to
get the desired effect then I'm going to
copy paste this setup to both our smooth
and rough plastic Master materials but
instead of smudges I'll use this grunge
texture and add it to the existing
roughness setup we already have just try
to keep these things subtle when you're
adjusting these settings in your
instance again you'll want to reference
the real thing throughout the entire
process to ensure that we match it as
close as possible for the cartridge I
used all the same plastic textures but
I'll touch on two cool things for you
guys first off I found all all these
cartridge stickers on Reddit by user
physical green 7603 link below for you
guys and second once you got them
imported you can make different
instances of different stickers with
only one master material if you
rightclick the image texture in the
master material convert it to a
parameter and when toggled in the
instance you can easily switch them out
it's pretty
sweet so this thing is looking nice
right now this is looking really nice
you can swap out any of these materials
for a bunch of different looks using any
of the GSG materials I definitely spent
hours here cuz all of this lighting is
set up our model is looking beautiful
and no matter what texture we throw down
onto this thing it's just going to look
real nice real nice but we ain't done
yet because I want to build out a little
scene for this game boy to live in and
see if we can't add some light being
filtered through a window onto a
background or something the asset or
tool that we'd use to achieve this
effect is called a goo which according
to wikkipedia stands for something like
go between I guess meaning we'll put a
card between our light source and our
subject to shape the light in a specific
way gray skill gorilla has a bunch of
them animated ones too even but let's
just pull one of their static window
Goos we'll drag it into our content
browser and create a new material by
right clicking and selecting material
and once we open it up we just have two
simple things to do first off we're
going to change our material domain to
light function then I'm going to grab
our goo texture
and pipe it into emissive color and if
we right click our image texture and
promote it to a parameter like we did
with our cartridge stickers we can
switch our Gobo via the material
instance I'll drag out a spotlight from
the place actor's window and when we
scroll down we'll find this light
function slot where we can drag our
light function material into and if we
position this Spotlight just right we
can get the exact effect we're going for
you can adjust the spotlight intensity
and inner and outer spread to to lock in
the look so far this has been a Whopper
of a tutorial and I want to thank you
guys who are still with me at this point
cuz we're not done yet all right let's
talk animation so that we can talk
render
settings to animate our game boy we need
to create a timeline in Unreal Engine
and we can do that by right-clicking in
the content browser going to cinematics
in selecting a level sequence if we open
this up you'll see we got a timeline
where we can change our frame rate our
timeline duration and drag and drop
anything that we want to animate from
our outliner so in this case I probably
want to animate the camera and The Game
Boy itself but instead of just animating
the Game Boy and this cartridge
separately here's what I'm going to do
to make it easy in the place actor's
window I'm going to search for a cube
and drag it on out and once I position
it to the center of our game boy I'll
drag our Game Boy and cartridge into the
cube now this only works if they're both
set to movable this is very important
cuz it it won't work otherwise that goes
for anything you want to drop into this
Cube that we're going to animate now if
we rotate this Cube anything inside will
rotate with it we're essentially just
using the cube as a null object so I'll
drag the cube into the sequencer drop
down the transform options make a key
frame for the appropriate axis move to
the end of our timeline rotate that
thing 360 and make another key frame
sweet two more things though let's
select the cube search for visible and
uncheck that cuz yeah obviously and
second we want this to Loop but our key
frames are easing into their movement
and we want them to have linear motion
so I'll right click each one and set
them to linear key now we got a nice
little 360 Loop here but let's add a
little spin move at the end to spice it
up and instead of trying to blend our
new key frames into these existing key
frames which would honestly just take me
forever we're going to add another
transform Track by clicking this little
plus next to the transform layer and
selecting additive now we have have
another little isolated transform track
to play with and I'll essentially just
do the same move from before but over a
shorter period of time here right at the
end spin move to get the cartridge to
pop out the top we'll just drag it into
the sequencer and key frame the position
values to adjust our key frame handles I
can open up the curve editor and tweak
them a bit until it's feeling right and
you'll probably need to rightclick the
key frames and change its style to break
or weighted tangents for full control
and with a bit of tweaking you got
yourself a smooth punchy Game Boy
animation but y'all it's time to talk
rendering because one of the biggest
things that I learned through this
project is how powerful the path Tracer
is if you thought the Lumen lit mode
looked nice man just switch over to the
path Tracer and guess again the biggest
difference to me is in the ambient
occlusion light just falls off way more
naturally and if you take a look at
these comparison pictures you can see
what I mean how the Shadows are just a
lot more accurate and when you want
something to look as good as possible
and can spare a bit of render time the
path Tracer is your answer you can
control its settings for the viewport in
the post-process volume we created
earlier but to control our actual render
settings our export settings we're going
to have to go a step deeper with the
movie render queue which is what I
always use to export my animations from
unreal if we open up our sequence and
click this little clapboard we should
see the movie render queue and if not
you'll just need to toggle the plugin
and restart once inside though I'll
click on unsaved config to set things up
The Path Tracer requires a special setup
but it's not too difficult it's as easy
as deleting deferred rendering clicking
this green setting button up at the top
and selecting path Tracer that's it we
don't need to mess with any of these
settings here but what we do need to add
is some anti-aliasing to make this work
just be sure to check override
anti-aliasing to ensure that we're
controlling it from these export
settings as opposed to our post-process
volume or something now we control our
samples with these two inputs the
spatial and temporal sample counts and
they multiply each other right so 500 in
spatial and one in temporal equals 500
samples as does 50 in spacial 10 in
temporal why change these numbers like
this because the temporal samples
control how clean our motion blur is and
since we have this sweet spin move at
the end of our animation these settings
will do us just right but feel free to
add more if you want and lastly instead
of a JPEG sequence I'll add an exr
sequence set to dwaa for the best
compression settings and under output
make sure our resolution and path are
correct once you have all this set up we
can save them as a preset which really
comes in handy later on when outputting
more renders and you can even take this
file and transfer it across other unreal
projects you can send it to friends or
even load it into your default scene
that we set up earlier and with that
we'll hit render do some light color
grading in Da Vinci add some sweet music
some sweet sound effects and enjoy the
fruits of our
[Music]
labor I really hope you guys had a good
time with this video and are inspired to
create some of your own art after
definitely download this project file
for free by clicking the link down below
and if you want to challenge yourself
this week the weekly challenge theme on
my Discord server is main menu where
we're challenging you to create or
reimagine a main menu for a retro video
game so head on over I got a link for
you guys down below leave me a comment
too let's talk Unreal Engine hit me up
with any questions you got let's get
into some feedback on this video maybe
talk some video games perhaps I'm down
for it all happy rendering everybody
happy thanks giving if y'all are
celebrating and I'll catch yall later
[Music]
peace
he